we are at the halfway point
of the 2022
nba all-star game
michael jordan
among those honored at halftime it was a
great ceremony in earth wind and fire
there
chuckster was part of it shaq was part
of it was great stuff
just great stuff uh unbelievable you
know as a basketball fan
i was emotionally watching this man it
was fun to see man i know you can't hear
we don't have your ear pizza and that's
okay that's okay
you wanna you got your mic
if you can hear us
how did you how did you feel tonight uh
being out there
it was wonderful
seeing some of the guys
and these guys mean a lot to me because
you know basketball means a lot to me
excuse me you know i've never had a real
job because of that stupid basketball
and all those guys out there
made my life great
and i just want to thank the older guys
because it wasn't for the older guys
we wouldn't be who we were but it was
really emotional
i was glad to be a part of and i just
want to thank everybody and the fans are
important the fans are really important
to the whole picture
but there's so many people who have
helped me in my life
this goes to everybody in my life who's
helped me
[Music]
an 11-time all-star and 11-time all-nba
team selection charles barkley
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
a 10-time all-star and six-time all-nba
team selection
carmelo anthony
[Applause]
a nine-time all-star and seven-time
all-nba team selection
dominique wilkins
[Applause]
[Music]
an 11-time all-star and 10-time all-nba
team selection elgin baylor
a 14-time all-star and two-time league
mvp karl malone
an 11-time all-star and two-time league
mvp
bob pettits
[Applause]
an eight-time all-star and six-time
all-nba team selection rick barry
[Music]
a 10-time all-star and four-time all-nba
team selection paul erizen
an eight-time all-star and four-time all
nba team selection anthony davis
[Music]
[Applause]
a 12-time all-star and 12-time all-nba
team selection
dolph chase
a two-time league mvp and six-time
all-star
giannis attended kunpo
[Applause]
a 12-time all-star and six-time all-nba
team selection elvin hayes
a three-time nba champion and three-time
league mvp
larry bird
a two-time nba champion and eight-time
all-star dave da busher
a two-time nba champion and 12-time
all-star kevin durant
[Music]
a 10-time all-star and four-time all-nba
team selection paul pierce
[Applause]
a 15-time all-star and nine-time all-nba
team selection kevin garnett
a seven-time all-star and five-time
all-nba team selection from middletown
ohio
jerry lucas
[Applause]
a 14-time all-star and 12-time all-nba
team selection
dirk nowitzki
[Applause]
a five-time nba champion and 15-time
all-star
tim duncan
an eight-time nba champion and 13-time
all-star john havlicek
a six-time nba champion and 10-time
all-defensive team selection
scotty pippen
[Applause]
a four-time all-star and four-time
all-nba team selection billy cunningham
[Applause]
[Music]
an 11-time all-star and seven-time
all-nba team selection
julius irving
[Music]
a two-time nba champion and two-time
defensive player of the year kawhi
leonard
[Applause]
[Music]
a three-time nba champion and seven-time
all-star kevin mchale
[Applause]
[Music]
a three-time nba champion and seven-time
all-star
james worthy
[Music]
a five-time nba champion and two-time
defensive player of the year
dennis rodman
[Applause]
[Music]
a four-time nba champion and four-time
league mvp from akron ohio
lebron
james
[Music]
you